You got the wrong name tags on.
This is just a sample of our competence.
If you think this is bad, wait until we really get into action.
Yeah, just fill it up to that.
Well, keep it going; you got to get two balls on there.
Well, I'll see if I can do better.
Oh my God.
See, I'm very generous.
They're gonna order from you from now on, not from me.
Who had the bad luck to draw me?
If you want anything later on, it's on me.
The cone is okay.
I would love a vanilla cone.
A vanilla cone.
Is that all you want today?
That would do it.
How long ago did you buy Dairy Queen,...
...and what was it that made it look good?
I've known Dairy Queen all my life.
Dairy Queen actually started in the 1930s and...
Wow!
...and a couple of guys worked up soft ice cream...
...and when they were contemplating selling, he thought of Berkshire,...
...who, better than some guy, that loves the product,...
...and we made a deal and we lived happily ever after.
Hi, welcome to Dairy Queen.
Can I take your order?
I'll have small Oreo Blizzard.
That would be three dollars and 23 cents.
Can you pull forward to the next window?
Okay.
Oh wow!
That is for you.
Good job on this one.
Love to have you here.
Thank you.
See you.